president Trump's nominee for attorney
journalist defending Robert mullahs
Russia investigation saying he will let
it finish
William Bar repeatedly promised senators
during yesterday's confirmation hearing
that he will be independent I will not
be bullied into doing anything I think
is wrong if I was ever asked to do
something that I thought was unlawful
and and directed to do that I wouldn't
do it and I would resign rather than do
it Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
outside the room where the hearing
continues today Nancy good morning to
you what did mr. Barr say about making
the special counsels report public
yesterday well he was actually asked
about that gale over and over again and
he said he was committed to transparency
but he would not commit to releasing
Muller's findings in full at the end of
the investigation he said that he and
Muller are longtime friends that he
doesn't believe that Muller is on a
witch-hunt as the president so often
claims but last June Barr did send an
unsolicited memo to DOJ officials
slamming the Muller investigation which
caused some Democrats to openly wonder
in the hearing if he's already biased
against the investigation now Barr
wouldn't commit to recusing himself from
the investigation he said that is up to
him not DOJ ethics officials but still
the chair of this committee does expect
him to be confirmed all right Nancy
thank you so much